yo check out my blog I love swag at WWII
looks swag comm backslash swag oh you
said I love swag that comes right move
org and you already know what it is real
92 three men boot like keV post Malone
what's going the second date of the tour
is officially over me yeah this man hey
first of all I want to talk about Stoney
because I feel like we've been waiting
for this album further for like a year
and a half and you're telling me beggin
you telling me talk about like the
direction of the project I love the name
of it obviously it's a great name thank
you you know that's what the that's what
they used to come here whenever I used
to smoke weed Stoney yeah stunning
Maloney Stoney Maloney but I don't smoke
weed anymore just cigarettes
yeah just lots of cigarettes dude
they're better for you right we're just
we're just like I said we're just like
figuring things out and I think we're
making a sound that's super super fresh
and it's original and hip original you
know very fly you can hip hop to it you
can crunk to it you really just get down
you performed a song tonight that has
quavo honor championships right
congratulations that's right we were
just seeing a chance but I'm so Cuevas
on the album who else do you have on the
debut album of Postum alone the
long-anticipated
project I know Bieber's on it obviously
he just quavo Kalani shoutout to Kalani
for sure we're working on some very
special things and you know we got
Pharrell on there Wow you know we're
we're doing some cool stuff talk about
the Pharrell feature because how does
that process begin does he hit you up
you guys
were you guys at the studio together
because obviously it's to 2016 so
there's so much mp3 and back-and-forth
and emails no yeah um he initially hit
me up and we yeah we met at Bonnaroo and
he said get it let's get into the studio
so whenever that whole run was done we
we got in the studio in LA and just not
that so you guys rented studio so you've
worked with Kanye you work with Pharrell
what have you learned from because
everyone always says like in the studio
with guys like you know Dre Kanye and
Pharrell like it's always like they're
so meticulous with the creative process
what did you take from I mean not a lot
of people can say they work with both of
those guys right maybe push your team
but but what did you take from from from
both of those experiences you know kind
of keep it with you I mean I learned a
lot I mean whether a lot of a lot of
conscious learning and a lot of
subconscious learning right now from the
way that watching the way that they work
and you know picking up little and
traits that they do in the studio that
you know they're both geniuses so it's
just surrounding yourself with that type
of energy just like he no rubs off on
you and
one day I'll be cool - yo man fade is
like in the new life we live with this
Teyana Taylor video Shaq made one I saw
the Shaq one how did you feel when you
saw that move shag is out here he's kind
of moved he does but how did the
original like like I remember you were
in Tampa the day before you went to the
Fashion Show in New York we did a show
in Tampa and the next day you went to
New York and they played that record I
think it was that was the record they
played during the fashion show right
yeah yeah I remember Dre hidden he's
like I don't want to do the English
accent this would be terrible breath I
brought hey you see the cornered fashion
show we got a new record with Thai and
Kanye nonetheless had the record come to
be like Nala - yeah I was terrible I'm
not ever gonna be in movies but um but
did Kanye reach out to you how did the
Kanye product like like like situation
transpired cuz it's a year later and
that songs very important right now I
met him at highly Jimmy's birthday when
I did I remember that yep
kylie jenner's birthday he was early on
the wave yeah man you know she's she's a
big fan she's awesome both big fans
right I love her
it's
it's like whenever you meet somebody
face-to-face it's really easy it after
that point to like connect once you get
it out he's that initial thing other way
it's like so then Kanye hits me up and
says let's get into the studio and we do
and you know we made a couple junks a
tough one be honest Tony guess so if it
ever comes out for sure um when it comes
to Stoney obviously you work with first
a lot like he's responsible for a lot of
your sound as far as production ready
and he's as possible for a lot of dope
features but talk about production wise
where you're going with the album I
heard the record you did tonight has a
little spruce my Michael made it right
no the congratulations is Metro boomin
that's a metro we're just talking about
race drummer Frank yeah we're back
Jackie
we're back it's working hi well yeah
it's a metro boomin and you say Frank
Dux right hmm who else is producing on
the album and then we got some first we
got some horse it only be right we got
Louisville
okay Louise alone I've heard of bourbon
a [__] and mean you know P
it's a lot of cool stuff there it's a
lot of good [__] it's a lot of good [__]
buy a lot of different I'm curious too
cuz I was like kind of offended when the
devil XL cover came out because you
weren't on it and then I saw that girls
interview with The Breakfast Club and
she said what she said in the new set we
use it on Instagram right and then I
heard that you turned it down what is
the real story with the double XL thing
the double XL thing is that I had to go
all the way to New York and then she
talked [__] people people have a natural
inclination to just talk [__] about
things I feel like you've been dealing
with that from the jump listen it's my
life it's my life I live for people to
talk [__] up a little bit you know I
have a lot of people that really [__]
with me heavy as 50 cent hurt mood yeah
I know you guys we work together yeah
did in New York he came out and it's
like the best iPhone music video ever
thank you
he has this iPhone app it just straight
up I think billion shout-out to Jay and
the cooler in the video yo man but but
like I'm your your music fan obviously
like you have Bob Dylan's had it on the
arm Kurt Cobain's had it on our shot to
Danny
yeah Johnny cat Dan
but I'm curious like for me as a hip-hop
fan like that debut album is always so
important because you think of guys like
like 50 cent or get rich or die trying'
knowledge Illmatic whatever you want to
say as far as debut albums when you
approach this project because you just
put out the tape what was that like
which was nice because that was kind of
needed ya know definitely was yeah it
was definitely needed at the time but
when you approach the debut album are
you thinking like yo I gotta make it I
got it does does that even come through
your head like I need to like make a
project that stands up with you know
with some of the best debut album of all
time because obviously in hip-hop that's
how people look is she right yo snoop
came out with doggy style off the game
but I don't look at you necessarily I
just look at you as an artist right but
what's your what's your thought process
is going into the debut album and kind
of like well it's like it's like I think
I think that it is important to hit it
hard right out the gate you know what I
mean and I mean that's I'm at the at the
same time is trying to like hit it out
of the park
all that [__] I'm just trying to make
music that a lot of people haven't heard
like I sound like that before you know
what I mean I think I think that it's a
really dope project that you can turn up
to and you can get weird to with your
friends and some lady friends and I
think that it's just super super fresh
and new and I think it's gonna hit
really hard I just hope that people are
patient wait I gotta ask you a song like
go flex yeah it's one of my favorite
records and I've been writing from the
beginning but go flex is a record that I
heard and I thought was I was like I
think it the way was released it was a
release like the first single from the
album right I didn't do what it was
supposed to do at least in my opinion
that radio when a record that's so good
like that or a record like the [__] like
I know too young was the follow-up to
why diversity when records like that
don't necessarily pop on the radio or
remains
when the efforts foot there is it
frustrating how do you feel in that type
of [__] happens cuz I mean it's what can
you do right yeah you know if if it
doesn't do what it's supposed to do you
know that's not really a problem but I
don't really I don't really I don't
really take my Records is supposed to do
anything you know I think it's just
music that I put out and whatever the
label wants to do with it then you know
they can do with it but I just I'm just
focused on making music that I like how
do you feel about the Cowboys this year
to Romo's out he's gone
dak Prescott Ezekiel Elliott did your
dad work for the Cowboys or something
so you got two tickets on lock if you
ever wanna go yeah it's late yeah Stoney
the album coming soon hopefully it's
definitely coming out for the indie hero
for the yes it's coming up you're
performing are you saving a new record
from the album throughout the tour like
each day trying to okay so at the very
least you're gonna be able to go on
youtube and watch videos of him
performing exactly because my the end of
the tour give any concert call him for a
possible buddy appreciate your element
good good